So the Stratton Taxonomy's 6th optimization technique is called compaction.
And John has described compaction a couple of times.
He described it in unit 4 and revisited it in unit 6,
where it comes up in sparse matrix vector multiply and in-graph traversal.
So I'm not going to go into great length describing what compaction is.
Just as a quick review,
compaction is useful when you have a computation to perform
on a set of elements but the exact elements that require computation are not known in advance.
If most of the elements require computation,
then its simplest just to assign threads to every element
and just have every thread check to see whether they should process or not.
The threads that are active will do whatever they are suppose to do.
The threads that will not will simply return.
In that case you will end up storing something valid--
some valid output in most cells
and the cells in the output are the--
the elements in the output where the thread wasn't active,
because it didn't need to be processed you will end up with leaving blank.
Now if relatively few of the elements require computation,
then you're wasting a lot of storage on the output,
and you're doing less efficient computation,
because a lot of your threads are sitting idol, instead of doing some sort of useful work.
Compacting the elements means creating a dense array containing only active elements.
So that then you can do your processing on the stents array,
producing a dense output array directly.
You're not wasting storage on all these invalid, null output elements,
and you're not wasting computation
on all these threads that are just sitting around not doing anything
while the other threads in their thread block are--
the relatively few threads in this thread block
that have active elements have have anything useful to do.
So as a quiz, suppose that only every 8th element will be processed.
So here I've drawn the elements that will be processed
and all the ones I've left blank will not be processed.
And the idea is that every 8th element--it requires processing.
And assume that we're compute limited;
in other words, that whatever operation is we're going to do on these every 8 elements
is expensive,
and that's the limiting factor rather than the memory bandwidth to fetch elements.
So assume that we are limited by computation and not memory bandwidth.
So the question is about how much less time
will the computation take
if a thread is launched to run on every element of the compacted array
rather than if the thread is launched to run for every element of the original array?
In other words, how much faster is it going to be to run on a compacted array?
Will it be 8x faster, will it be 4x faster, will it be the same speed, 1x faster?
And then I want to ask,
what if only every 32nd element will be processed,
and what if only 128th element must be processed?
So for the answer I'm looking for an integer like 4 or 8 or 16 or 32 or 1,
and you're telling me whether its 4 times faster, 8 times faster, 1 times faster and so on.